[Music]
a couple of weeks ago pixar released its
newest film a coming-of-age tale about
two young boys in italy who
spend a summer getting into mischief
going on adventures discovering the true
meaning of friendship etc
uh the twist is that both of the boys
luca
and alberto are actually sea monsters
and when they venture in
onto dry land they assume the appearance
of human beings but whenever they're in
the water
they revert back to their true sea
monster form this
apparently is the plot now not to give
away the ending but
eventually everybody on land learns that
the boys are actually sea monsters and
things get a little hairy at first but
then they all learn to accept luca and
alberto
for who they are while more importantly
luca and alberto learn to accept
themselves
and i don't need to see the movie to
tell you it ends that way almost every
kid's movie since the dawn of time
has been at some level a coming-of-age
story and there's almost always
prominent themes of
self-acceptance of being yourself and so
on pixar isn't doing anything new here
even the sea monster bit is clearly
reminiscent of the little mermaid a
disturbing tale about a monstrous
aquatic freak who crawls onto land and
stalks a young prince
eventually ensnaring him in a romantic
relationship on false pretenses
the only thing that's arguably unique
about luca
is that the film centers around male
friendship
there is no romance here unlike in
little mermaid
now when i was growing up those kinds of
stories were a little more common the
sandlot is one example
i was a big fan of that movie as a kid
but these days
most movies feel the need to shoehorn in
some kind of romance angle and of course
there always
has to be at least as many female
protagonists as male
luca slightly breaks from that mold it
seems by telling a more simple
innocent straightforward story of two
young boys who become friends
but nothing is allowed to be simple and
innocent and straightforward anymore
now when there's so much indoctrinating
to be done and so little time to do it
and that's why
many people on the lgbt left and the
media have spent the last several days
insisting
that luca must in fact be a gay movie
it's not a gay movie the boys are not
gay
and there's no romance between them
which is good because the characters are
pre-pubescent children
we're not yet at the point where pixar
will release a movie about
eight-year-old boys in love
we may get there eventually but for some
on the left that time can't come soon
enough they're impatient
and that's why if you go to twitter and
you search for luca right now
you'll find many tweets like this from a
guy named eric rosewood
or rosswood i think self-professed lgbt
activist
and author of the book the ultimate
guide for gay dads
and he tweeted quote just saw luca and i
don't care what anyone else says
it's the first gay animated film by
disney pixar feeling like you might have
have to hide a part of yourself meeting
someone you like for the first time
strangers calling you and your friends
monsters
finding the good ones i cried
now he's not alone in this assessment a
headline from buzzfeed says
i'm sorry but luca is totally a gay
movie and that's why i loved it so much
screen rant announces why luca is an
lgbtq story despite what pixar says
the av club has a lengthy missive
explaining in strenuous detail
why the gay interpretation of luca is
entirely valid
and vanity fair takes a more sort of
middle-of-the-road approach with its
contribution to this discussion the
headline
is luca pixar's first gay movie
maybe we should note meanwhile that the
director of the film
who may be considered an authority on
what the movie is about
has addressed these claims and clarified
that no it's not a gay thing
the boys are just friends boys are
allowed to be friends
in fact most boys have friends who are
boys
and there's nothing sexual about it this
is quite normal and healthy
what is not normal healthy is to see all
male friendship
even prepubescent fictional animated
male friendship
through a sexual lens the insider
website has taken a different approach
accepting that luca is not a gay story
and castigating pixar for lacking the
courage
to sexualize a relationship between two
elementary age children
the author jacob sarkeesian
he writes while the implications of
queerness are there
particularly in the friendship between
luke and alberto it's disappointing
that disney's pixar wasn't brave enough
to fully commit to their first
queer animated tale he continues luca is
immediately taken by the free-spirited
alberto
when that when he meets a fellow sea
monster off the coast of
porto rosso they're casually physical
with one another sleeping side by side
under a star-filled sky
wrapping their arms around each other's
waists and watching the sun set together
in fact they spent a lot of time
embracing one another teasing that their
relationship could blossom
into something more the comparisons to
call me by your name a film where two
young men fall in love
are well earned the italian seaside
setting the hazy beauty of the summer
scenery
and the tale of two boys experiencing
love for the first time
now sarkeesian begrudgingly accepts that
the nine-year-olds in the cartoon
aren't sexually interested in each other
uh it's just that he's disappointed
his all he says this may seem refreshing
to some to see
a disney movie explore friendship as
opposed to a fairy tale love story but
it's a shame that this decision has come
when a gay romance could have so easily
and naturally been explored
making luka and alberto explicitly gay
or queer wouldn't have felt contrived
it would have been a meaningful
confirmation of what is already a story
rich
in gay subtext yes
why tell any other kind of story when
you could have so easily told a gay one
why does sylvester stallone fight carl
weathers and rocky when they could have
been gay lovers instead
why is apollo 13 about an aborted lunar
mission when it could have been a
romance between
two gay astronauts on mars a kind of
brokeback mountain in space type of
thing
and by the way i hope you'll admire my
restraint in refraining from making a
uranus joke right here i'm not doing
that
but why should any story be told if it's
not a mechanism for sexual
indoctrination
why should anything exist if it's not
ideologically useful to progressives
these are the questions that torment our
friends on the left
and the questions are all the more
disturbing when applied to a movie about
eight or nine-year-old boys um
it's bad enough for them to sexualize
children as they do
but now they're offended when children
are not sexualized
the writer of that insider article is
experiencing
something like moral indignation at the
fact
that a couple of prepubescent cartoon
characters aren't depicted in an
explicitly sexual embrace
i'd really hate to see what sort of
improvements quote unquote this weirdo
would make
to those stories of male friendship that
i grew up watching
don't let them anywhere near the sand
lot that's all i can say
don't let them anywhere near an actual
sandlot either if there are kids on it
the implications here go beyond movies
and cartoons the real point for these
leftists with their half-baked
freudian notions is that all people
are driven primarily by sexual impulses
and this includes children
to them in their dark pedophilic vision
of reality
innocent platonic friendships don't
exist can't exist
they see two boys with their arms around
each other and they think well why would
anyone behave this way unless it's for
sexual reasons
no other kind of love no other sort of
bond
can or should be formed and this kind of
over sexualization of everything
makes it more difficult for boys in
reality to form those platonic loving
bonds with each other
when we hear so much about a lack of
representation in film
well male friendship is not represented
very
represented very often or very well and
so boys are not provided with examples
of what those relationships look like
and here we see part of the reason why
pixar can't even put out a movie about a
couple of sea monsters becoming friends
without leftists trying to drape a
rainbow flag over the whole thing
[Music]
and for that reason they are of course
all of them together
very much cancelled listen
hit that subscribe button right now do
it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated